yeah I mean look this is a giant report
it was two years in the making of
commission led by Gordon Brown about
UK's future what is it's 155 Pages
there's 40 recommendations it is uh to
quote circus starmer in his view an
attempt of the biggest transfer of power
from Westminster to devolve governments
to the English Mayors to local
authorities it is to quote him an
attempt by labor to fix Britain's broken
Politics as he sees it and fix Britain's
broken economy and what was in it well
the two main points really is this focus
on the Devolution of economic political
and even tax raising powers from the
center to the regions as I said to
English Mayors to devolved governments
and secondly constitutional reform and
the big highlight really if you like all
the big sort of eye-catching uh proposal
there is the app abolition of the House
of Lords but you're right I mean the two
obvious questions from it is this
another politician talking the big talk
but will he actually walk the walk and
will these things get done and two at a
time when people are really struggling
uh with the immediate pressures of the
cost of living worrying about feeding
their families and paying their bills
striking uh over inadequate pay deals as
they see it is this really the moment to
talk to them about abstract Notions of
constitutional reform and Devolution
that doesn't really mean much to people
in the short term so those are what the
questions are about and Care starmer
answered them but I've got someone else
to answer them with me now as well it's
Lisa nandi she's the shadow Secretary of
leveling up and the MP for wig and where
my family's from so
um Lisa thanks for joining us on Sky I
mean that's really the first question I
have for you you know the conservatives
taught the talk on leveling up or
Northern Powerhouse and people feel
disenfranchised and they feel that those
promises perhaps haven't been met in
parts of the world such as Leeds or
Wigan why is Kia sir Kia any different
why is Labor any different it's just a
report that talks to Westminster it's
not going to go anywhere
is about nice to have about Regional or
local development we see
heart of Britain original malaise if you
write off the contribution that most
people in most parts of Britain have to
make they're never going to grow your
economy you're never going to have
enough to retain good Public Services
the decent housing the decent bus and
transport networks that people rely on
it's not just that we demand more out
it's that we've got to put more in we've
got a contribution to make in all parts
of this country including here in Leeds
where we're standing today and that's
why we're going to transfer out of
Westminster and Whitehall to two
communities so they can drive that local
growth and they can start building an
economy that works again but at least
nandy you do recognize at the moment
when people watch that they'll be like
what on Earth the labor talking about I
can't feed the family my pay rise is not
going to cover my bills they're like why
are you telling us this now you get that
don't you because all of these problems
connect up to one Central problem that
we're the most centralized country in
the world and we've got a small group of
ministers sitting in Westminster
hundreds of miles away from the
community is that they seek to govern
micromanaging decisions over housing
over bus routes we heard from Tracy
brabin the mayor of West Yorkshire today
that she has the ability to cap fares on
the buses which she's done but people
ring her and say Tracy I can't get a bus
because she doesn't have the power to
determine roots and what uses a capped
bus fare if there isn't a bus to get on
these are the real problems that people
are grappling with every day of their
lives and if we tilt the balance of
power back to people who've got a stake
in the outcome and skinning the game
they will build a country that works and
does did you recognize though that talk
about abolish in the house of laws at
this moment in people's lives like what
are they talking about as if people are
thinking about that they're just not
right now are they well if all we were
talking about was abolishing the House
of Lords I'd say that you had a point
but the abolition of the House of Lords
is part of reforming our broken system
of government so that power is in the
right hands and to empower every part of
our country our Nations and regions
we've got to end is this broken model of
politics where a small number of people
who are unelected unaccountable exert a
tight grip over our systems of
governance and the decisions that
directly affect people's lives put it
all together and what you've got is the
greatest transfer of power and resources
out of Westminster and Whitehall into
the hands of people who know better than
we do what assets and potential exist in
their communities get behind those
communities and back them to do well and
listen Andy in those 40 recommendations
you would have obviously read the report
what are the most important things for
you the most important thing is that
we're we're going to move power and
resources out of Westminster and
Whitehall whether that's control over
housing and planning over culture skills
and training and job centers these are
all things that at the moment local
leaders are crying out for it's not just
labor leaders people like Andy Street in
the West Midlands are desperate to be
able to get their hands on the levers of
growth so they can rebuild thriving
places where your people don't have to
get out to get on and where everybody
gets to the chance to contribute to the
nation's success and just finally some
of us struggled to get up here today in
time because a train was canceled the
country looking at these rail streets
right in the run-up to Christmas what's
your message to the union should they
take that pay deal and that offer of
last night they've rejected it it took
me three and a half hours to get from
Wigan to Leeds 49 miles yesterday and
there was no strike on the problems with
our Railways stem from the fact that
we've had private operators who've been
stripping resources out of our public
services and as a consequence they're
running a model where they ask people to
work overtime in order to run the trains
rather than having enough well-paid
well-treated staff to run our Railways
properly we're going to end that system
we've committed to renationalizing our
Railways and handing control and power
of resources around transport to local
leaders who wouldn't just try and
connect country up north to south but
east to west as well this is the thing
that's really holding this country back
it's ruining people's lives we can't
just put sticking clusters on these
problems we've got to fundamentally
change the system okay listen Andy thank
you very much for joining us on Sky News
there you have it then that's Lisa nandi
the shadow leveling up uh secretary
talking about the importance of
devolution and putting power and
autonomy back into the hands of local
leaders but acknowledging too that some
of these reforms at this moment in time
alone might seem irrelevant to the
public such as reforming or abolishing
the House of Lords and I guess the real
question is what is Circus starmer and
the labor party trying to do here well
they are now 20 plus points ahead in the
polls ahead of the conservative party
and what this is really is one senior
advisor put it to me yesterday this is
the beginning of kierstarma trying to
impress upon the public that this is a
prime minister faster in waiting and a
labor government in Waiting they're
ahead in the polls but the question is
whether people at this time see these
reforms as relevant and I guess the big
question is how many make it from the
recommendations of the report into a
labor Manifesto